hello everyone and welcome to bloodline
the taxonomy of fear where we examined
what if anything makes a movie scary and
this week we're going to be tackling the
issue of remake yay or nay with the new
evil dead Sam Raimi's original and
beloved movie which came out in 1981 was
a clearing house of horror movie cliches
what do we got drowned out bridge five
friends cabin in the woods demonic
possession and this movie really brings
that all together it's the first
directorial effort from Uruguay and
director Fede Alvarez who oddly note
this is his first film because he really
demonstrates some mastery here but he
was picked up from just like what was it
a five minute short film called panic
attacks I filmed a panic attack once and
I did not get a movie deal oh well I
watch your panic attack it's happening
right now alright what makes a good
horror remake Jordan well we're gonna
start off with the source material has
to be a fine balance between crappy
enough and good enough it has to be bad
enough to where you want to remake it
because you want to be able to improve
on the original source material but it
has to be good enough to have a built-in
fan base and the kind of perfect ground
for that is a cult classic like Evil
Dead which also makes it dangerous
because it's just it's so endeared to so
many PS you haven't even be giving me
judge on that end result yeah and if you
take a movie that's so good to start out
with like The Shining or Carrie you're
really kind of gonna bury herself under
the weight of like of the original
expertise that happens there but this
movie I think really hit the perfect
balance of taking what evil dead did
originally and and bringing it into a
modern context in which if the original
filmmakers had had the budget they would
have done what we just saw us yes right
the second criterion is nostalgic but
fresh yes the remake needs to defer and
refer to the original movie so that it
feels familiar and comforting but not so
much that it feels stale like be shot
for shot remake of cycle we have me
asking why am I not just watching the
original yeah Hitchcock is no
cessary this is this is completely
superfluous what elevated this remake
was not so much the practical effects in
the gore which by that we're really
really good perfectly balanced between
understated and cartoonish uhuh right
down to the show shoot you can look at
what elevated this movie was what the
original lack which was backstory
motivation for shadowing and logic which
oddly enough you don't need a lot of
money to put in a movie and I think a
point that we we both really agreed on
when we talked about it the first time
was that the original Evil Dead had a
really good idea but the new Evil Dead
is a really good movie which kind of
brings me to my third to our third point
which is restraint just because you have
the ability now to do so much with so
many fewer resources doesn't mean you
should throw in everything and the
kitchen sink and even though this movie
was heinous liguori and incredibly
graphic I never felt low felt like it
stepped outside of the bounds just for
shock value it felt like it really
adhered to the vision of Sam Raimi and
stuck to the spirit of evil dead well
being so much more vigilant visually
enticing bloodiest ending I have seen in
a movie in a really long time and yet it
felt like merited it did did well felt
artistic
how many hours of sleep did you forfeit
to the Evil Dead Jay I want to say too
because I was fixated on the reason why
they went to the cabinet why they stay
really great which really which was
great it felt real believable and
ambiguous enough to keep me unsettled
were quite quite a while absolutely and
I am gonna go a full five hours because
i was super exhilarated after it and
we're kind of freaking out during the
school oh I was crawling out of my skin
and then I got home I couldn't really
sleep and then I woke up the next
morning and I really had to go to the
bathroom but I was too scared to get out
of my bed so I laid there for like at
least an hour waiting for the Sun came
up to feel safe enough with a full
bladder to actually go and relieve
myself well that sounds like remake yeah
yeah two thumbs up and four for Gore
Evil Dead all right survival lessons how
are we now girded going forward after
Evil Dead Jay all right number one
people of color beware if you are the
only person to color with a bunch of
white people about to go do something
even remotely dangerous step back a
little bit and say no thank you white
people I will sit this one out it is
2013 and we still die first I know these
lessons why haven't they been learned
yet and number two curiosity killed the
cat like all the cats like at least a
dozen cats and then set them on fire and
hung them from the rafters of a room so
just keep that curiosity to yourself
next time and finally number three
demons are really good impersonators
they're especially good at imitating
your sister your girlfriend yeah but a
crack who is offering you sexual
favors yeah do not believe them no
matter how enticing those favors okay
remake video pic of the week Jordan I'm
gonna go with 2010 s remake of the
crazies which originally came out in
1973 and had the same name and I am a
sucker for Timothy Olyphant but this is
just a straight-up great remake I mean
it's exciting it's scary it adheres
closely to the original I loved it I'm
gonna go with another 2010 movie I Spit
on Your Grave I highly recommend
watching the making of because it will
make you feel better about what you just
watched that's a really good idea well
that is it for this installment of blood
line and as always if you have any
questions
almonds concerns or just want to say
hello email us at bloodline at wired.com
and as we like to say here on the show
remember it's just a mood